we all come to a story with hopes and
expectations
looking for an answer
sometimes it would be better to live
with that hope
without ever finding the story
this is not the story you want it to be
this story
will eat you alive
this story
is a monster
and monsters wear many faces
[Music]
and she
said with our swords
we will forge new stories
to strike the gods that haunt us
you might see me as weak
but i will show you what lies behind my
eyes
we will embrace our
suffering soothe our scars of grief
and break their siege of our minds
you may see them as gods
we will show you
what lies behind their eyes
listen
it's coming
what's he saying
to risk your own life
for what you believe is your sacrifice
to make
to lead others to death
brings a different kind of burden
one that cena
would have to learn
i don't know
dad is coming
can you smell their fear
look at the bones
look at the bones that's going to be you
that's going to be everyone
[Music]
those whose eyes are clouded by fear are
besieged by the ghosts that haunt them
senua saw that to win the war we must
break this siege
break it
with an unshakable truth
break it
with an impossible feet
yes
[Music]
derek
come on
chase me run
run him down
[Applause]
oh
it's me it wants to count
[Music]
get ready
[Music]
attack
[Applause]
[Music]
help me
[Music]
[Music]
i know you he needs you
so
[Music]
[Music]
god
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
it happened an age ago
but when i recall i see it true
on a night of wintry fog
the rule of death was stolen
and the demigods began to fall
starting with godwin the golden
queen mariko was driven to the brink
[Music]
the shattering ensued a wall that
wrought only darkness
the elden ring was broken
but by whom
and why
what could the demigods ever hope to win
by boarding
[Music]
[Music]
the conqueror of the stars
general will die
and the blade of nicola melania the
seventh
these two were the mightiest to remain
and locked horns
[Music]
but there would be no victor
[Music]
and so we inhabit a fractured world
awaiting the arrival of the elderly
[Music]
unless of course
thou should take the crown
[Music]
[Music]
oh
this is
[Music]
it
um
[Music]
essentials
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hi
i'm thomas anderson
like many of you i work with computers
but computers are also mirrors
reflecting back who and what we are in
the choices we make
the worlds we build
we feel got it like riding a bike
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well well looks like it's bound voyage
to our old pals cuphead bug man and the
lovely miss chalice
they're off on their next adventure this
time to the fabled dlc island watch
challengers await in this enchanted land
[Music]
[Applause]
what better way to explore the island
then with a leisurely climb into the
mountains
just remember to watch your step
or perhaps the icy tundra is more to
your liking
don't forget to pack your mittens
look out for the warping winter wheel
next up the dramatic western plains
under the waterfall eye of sheriff
winchester yeehaw
but what's this
why is chef salt baker with his famous
cookies
he's the best baker in the land
his cookies are sure to put some pep in
your step
and you'll need it
for there's a new challenge waiting
around every corner on the amazing dlc
island
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
over here
so
it's too dangerous
[Music]
my daughter
a new threat comes to our shores
and i must call you home
restore what has been broken
unite old enemies
forge new ones
you are a hero
but you can be more
you can be
a leader
you
are wonder woman
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
who are you child my name is frey
holland i do not know how i got here
and all i want is to go home
she is hell spawn how else did she
survive in the corruption
the people are afraid they look to me in
the council for hope that we cannot give
them
but maybe you can
wherever i go turns to [ __ ]
it's always been this way
earthy has all but lost everything that
corruption touches it breaks yeah i saw
it up close
it is you who trespassed on my back
you who set this battle in motion
[Music]
how do you plead not guilty lies
she dies
[Music]
ever since the day the portal network
collapsed stranding us in these realms
we have searched for a way home
lost
and alone in the dangerous labyrinth of
fantastical worlds
welcome to the lands of faye
[Music]
every portal is a chance for salvation
[Music]
uniting the lost survivors
or leading us deeper
into this nightmare
nightingale
our beacon of hope
but beyond our reach
as long as we stand together
our journey will unite us
you
the realm walkers
are all that is left
[Music]
there it is
the biggest death trap in all history
and the dukes headed into its jaws on
kaladan we ruled with air and sea power
here we must scrabble for desert power
move slowly and the day of your revenge
will come this is your inheritance speed
is a device of shaytan thus there will
always be a desert on arrakis
what is to become the baron vladimir
and if anything
your face
[Music]
my vengeance
this is
[Music]
don't let him see us precious
they'll find us they'll see us
kill them no we must hide we can't let
them get their nasty filthy hands
oh
is that
it can't be
it is
just start at the beginning
we landed on mars
it looked wrong
like we were in a dream
and you warded sabadoon's ship
the wicked thing the lure yeah
we wanted to find her
try to gain the upper hand
but she was baiting us
what happened next my ghost brought me
back
we kept going
she knew we would
and that's when you saw the night
i'll never forget it
[Music]
they refuse to die
yeah just like us
and you're sure you're absolutely sure
it was light salvathun's illusions can
fool the senses no
i know what i saw
this is real what made you push forward
we needed to know what that thing was
we couldn't stop
what has she done
[Music]
[Music]
oh
hurry up
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wait for me
[Applause]
[Music]
when i think of the justice league
i think of wonder woman
superman
green lantern you don't want to mess
with that lot but you
barry
you're just the team mascot aren't you
mate the loser of the league folks the
fastest man alive it's
the [ __ ]
flash is alive and he's playing for team
brainiac
i gave you orders
kill the flash
i'll kill you myself
[Music]
nothing can stop me
[Music]
really
why don't you just mail me the bullet
i'm the eye in the sky taking point for
who else needs to bash it
oh
[Music]
you want to see what a real hero can do
come on
really thought flasher had
[Music]
you